hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from round five of
this year's Tata steel chess tournament
it lasted over 7 hours and it is women's
world champion je Engine with the white
pieces against one of the candidates of
the 2024 F candidates tournament ala Fus
J uh it's quite a quite a grueling game
quite a grind but you guys will love
this one and before we check it out we
even have a nice photo of this moment
there you have it the second move being
played by jjun a lot of bright colors in
the photo you can see that ala has some
sort of a chess patterned hoodie he
probably designed it himself and um
other than that I mean it's a pretty
pretty normal photo and no Refreshments
for ala he does have some gum maybe but
uh yeah that's pretty much it and Jun
with a big glass of water that she I I
believe refilled over the course of the
game a few times as it did last for over
7 hours now that being said let's check
it out it's quite a wild one je Engine
with the white pieces opens with Pawn to
D4 we have Pawn to E6 bya going for hor
with's defense and she does not um
continue in the spirit of the D4 opening
uh she switches it up to E4 and
transposes into the French um uh defense
we have Pawn to D5 and now e captures on
D5 going for the exchange variation of
the fren we have e captures and now
Knight to F3 uh we have Bishop to D6
Pawn to C four so again yeah very
standard stuff here Knight to to F6 and
pawn to C5 advancing this Pawn which is
somewhat rare but not incredibly rare
Bishop back to E7 by lza and now Bishop
to D3 uh we have Castles by both um J
engine and dza and now Bishop to G4 just
spinning the Knight H3 Bishop to H5 and
now there are a couple of moves that
where Rook E1 and G4 were played but
here we have Bishop to E3 and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game uh and uh here ala probably
should play something like Pawn to C6
and it does seem like a very solid move
to play uh but he plays Knight to C6
which could be considered a bit
anti-position uh not um Defending Your
Center like this and the Knight could
get attacked which does we have Knight
be to D2 Rook to E8 and now Bishop to B5
right away so she waited for The Rook to
be developed to pin the uh pin the
Knight and okay Knight to E4 uh grabbing
more space in the center putting
pressure on the Knight on D2 and she
plays Queen to A4 attacking the Knight
just threatening to win a pawn we have
Knight captures on D2 Knight captures
and now even Bishop to G5 saying if you
try to win a pawn here I'm going to win
a Pawn on E3 as the bishop and Rook are
attacking it so he does capture once the
mesop poz's pawn structure but now we
have Rook a to E1 defending on E3 and
okay all is a trade Bishop captures Rook
captur Rook captures and F captures he's
still stuck with the uh weak d double
the C6 Pawn but she also has a weakness
on E3 it's a backwards pawn it cannot be
Advanced to E4 easily and ala makes sure
that it doesn't Queen to E8 defends the
C6 pawn and keeps an eye on that E4
Square preventing Pawn to E4 so this is
now a longterm weakness but also so is
this so let's see who takes advantage of
the weakness better he she goes for Rook
to E1 uh and he goes Pawn to F5 again
stopping that pawn to E4 move uh and now
Queen to A6 the queen can go into the
attack with something like Queen to B7
but also the queen can go right back
with Queen to F1 and it's actually a
very tricky defense she found against
ala's next move Al Isa plays Pawn to F4
of course The Rook uh the pawn cannot
capture on F4 The Rook on E1 would hang
well you could play Pawn to E4 this is a
very very complicated Pawn to E4 Queen
to G6 and um if you could Advance the
pawn to E5 it could be great but then
Pawn to F3 comes so it's not that great
so instead after Pawn to F4 she goes
back with Queen to F1 and uh temporarily
sacrifices a pawn but she will win it
right back F captures on E3 and now she
goes back Queen to D3 so capturing the
Knight cannot happen due to Rook
captures Queen on E8 so Pawn to E2 by
Ala H and now she could win the pawn
right away with something like G4 but
she prefers to keep the pawn structure
intact for the moment uh goes Knight F3
and just threatens to pick up the pawn
alza goes Queen to F7 and this is
already uh trying to get too much out of
the position here ala uh should just
admit that there's not much more to to
the position offer a queen trade um she
she would probably trade ala would have
a set of doubled pawns here Knight E5
going after the C6 pawn and okay yeah
the game continues however alza played
Queen to F7 and now she just gets the E2
Pawn for free Knight KN to G5 attacks
the queen and also the H7 pawn and now
the idea is if you go Bishop to G6 then
she just grabs on E2 and maybe it was
even the the better course of action by
Ala for example Queen goes to F6 attacks
the D4 Pawn just KN back to F3 and now
the game continues with Rook to f8 and
it's still a very active position but
ala chose Queen to G6 he just uh goes
into an end game uh with a with a uh
well with a worst position Queen
captures and G6 Bishop captures and now
Rook captures on E2 it also wouldn't
help if you capture with the H1 if H
captures on G6 then G4 traps your Bishop
that would be a pretty bad maneuver so
Bishop captures on G6 she plays Rook
captures on E2 and now ala goes Pawn to
H6 and okay if you look at the material
it's completely equal but the C6 Pawn
will fall and she doesn't go for Knight
to E6 to go after the C7 Pawn uh rather
Knight to F3 to E5 and then for the C6
Pawn that's the correct way way to do it
Bishop to E4 she goes Knight to E5 we
have Pawn to A5 ala finds an active way
of defending the position if Knight
captures Pond then maybe Rook A6 attacks
the Knight the Knight moves you shift
The Rook to G6 you put pressure on G2 so
ala of course being very resourceful but
she calculates well and she goes for
Knight captures and C6 uh and ala first
goes Rook Pawn to A4 uh trying to be
annoying here of course stopping Pawn to
B4 is also crucial uh Rook to E3 and now
Rook to A6 going after the Knight and uh
you could go Knight to E5 here to
prevent Rook to G6 but then maybe
something like G5 can be played and okay
it's a pretty tricky position but still
after Rook to A3 H it should be winning
for white B B4 or B3
even uh will be winning for white but
you went for Knight to B4 and this
allows alira to shift the Rook over to
G6 and now as the G2 Pawn is hanging
Rook to E2 would would be a bit passive
and there's no reason to keep the pawn
on a light Square when your opponent has
a light Square Bishop so the pawn is
much better placed on a dark square like
G3 we have Pawn to H5 and now she just
played Rook to A3 and there's a a much
more elegant way of dealing with this
position uh but uh you know they were
already getting low on time she had some
12 minutes on the clock ala had 15
minutes on the clock uh and uh Rook to
A3 is not the most impressive way to
handle this A3 actually is uh and the
reason is uh now B3 is very strong you
don't want to play B3 for ala to log the
position in with A3 uh but uh first A3
and then B3 this is very strong and now
the idea is for example if H4 G4 and if
Rook to F6 now you just play B3 and uh
well uh the principle of many weaknesses
is definitely not siding with ala here
for example Rook to f8 uh she will go
after this Pawn as this is weak as well
C6 Knight back to B4 again goes after
the pawn and and okay ala can capture
here but now he has to defend the pawn
hard to say how he does The Rook to C8
and now there's the the past a pawn to
worry about there's the weak C6 point to
worry about and also uh there's now a
path for the black for the white king to
enter the game so this would be
completely winning for her but she went
to Rook to A3 first uh which seems like
a good idea because you can play King F2
defend the pawn and just capture the
pawn on A4 right away you don't have to
trade pawns uh but it turns out it
doesn't work Alesa play King to
f8 uh King to F2 and now Rook to F6 with
check forcing the the king away from the
G3 Pawn which he does King to E2 but now
ala just goes back Rook to G6 so now if
she captures on A4 ala will capture on
G3 and if he grabs those pawns then he
also has two connected pass pawns on the
king side so here we have Pawn to H4 uh
King to F if you play King to F2 then Al
Isa just repeats Rook Rook F6 and so on
so H4 was played uh but now King to E8
now alza is much much closer with the
King to the action and if the king gets
let's say to B7 then the past a pawn
will not be such a big deal so Rook to
E3 she brings The Rook back now even
with tempo as Knight captures on D5 is a
threat uh and prepares Pawn to pawn to
A3 Pawn to B3 which should have been
played right away King to D7 Now Pawn to
A3 but now Ala plays Rook to E6 and here
ala is being as usual very tricky the
idea is that if she plays Pawn to B3 now
then he will capture and after Rook
capture some B3 there's okay there are
no nasty discoveries some Bishop C2 a
discovery will be met with Rook to E3
blocking check so it's not impressive uh
but Rook to E8 is and here you can
easily stop the pawn for example Pawn to
A4 Rook to A8 and now if Rook to A3 you
play Rook B8 you attack the Knight and
now if Knight D3 you can trade captures
captures go King to C6 and now look at
this uh Pawn to A5 looks again looks
very scary but there's King Rook to f8
and now you don't have time for A6
because Rook F2 check would pick up the
Rook so you have to waste one move and
then once you waste the move King to B7
will be played and then black is safe
but yeah you have to uh uh you have to
first play B3 but of course she doesn't
she figures this out she plays King to
D2 now Rook to F6 again trying to get um
a hold of the F2 Square so she goes back
King D2 but now alera doesn't repeat he
goes Rook to f8 now he's much closer to
the A8 Square uh Pawn to B3 and now a
captures on B3 and here move 40 has been
reached so they gain more time on the
clock uh which is again incredibly
interesting because um you know when
like Paran makulu in the previous game
that we've shown he he played like 15
precise engine moves in a row uh with 30
seconds on the clock and then as soon as
he got to the extra hour he makes a
mistake similarly here Rook captures on
B3 is played and now Alesa should
continue with with his plan of Rook to
A8 for example Rook to A8 King to D2 and
now King to E6 the king is also very
scary now going to the king side if King
to C3 King to F5 and it's a game it's a
race however ala abandons this plan goes
Bishop to
G2 uh having the possibility of going
Bishop to F1 with check could also be
very important uh but it now doesn't
work and A4 should be played but there's
even a different way Rook to E3 is what
she goes 4 now ala goes back Bishop to
E4 he of course doesn't want to allow
Rook to E5 going after the pawns here so
Bishop back to E4 and now Knight to A2
so a bit of a Time loss here by Ala uh
Rook to B8 hoping to get Rook to B2
check in to win the Knight and now
Knight to C3 she plays it spectacularly
even allowing Rook to B2 check and
forcing her own King to the back rank so
Rook to B2 check King to E1 and now Rook
to B3 uh but now King King to F2 again
played very masterfully the idea is of
course if Rook captures on A3 then
Knight captures on e4 and after Rook
captures on E3 of course it's a winning
King and pawn end game for white white
is up a pawn and an extra Pawn always
wins the end game most of the time so
after King F2 we have Bishop back to H1
B Isa the only move left for him to play
now Knight to D1 to defending the pawn
and offering a rook trade of course ala
cannot trade he goes back Rook to B8 now
Rook to E5 attack attacking the two
pawns and here alza finally circums the
well everything the the difficult
position the the clock taking he plays
Pawn to G6 the only way to defend this
is King to C6 I will just show it
because it's really a lot of fun uh and
after Rook captures on H5 Rook to B3 is
the move and after Rook to G5 going
after this Pawn there's Rook to D3 you
attack the Knight and after King defends
now you capture on A3 and after the king
moves because if you go after the pawn
and this is kind of the whole point if
you capture this Pawn then Bishop to F3
check wins the Knight or if you defend
then Rook to A1 uh P pins you uh so
there's uh there's that uh but you have
to see that and uh it's it's not easy
you've been playing for seven hours
you've been in time trouble for most of
the game Ala plays G6 and now she just
uh goes back Rook to E1 attacks the
bishop Bishop to E4 and now Knight to C3
threatening Knight captures on e4 to win
the the D5 Pawn goes Rook to f8 with
check we have King back to G1 and now
Rook to F3 King to C6 was the only way
to continue fighting after Rook to F3
going after the Knight now it's just
game over alza offers a trade of minor
pieces uh but it doesn't work for one
move specifically and you guys will
decide on that of course the bishop was
captured and after d captures an E4 what
is the move that ala missed in his
calculations while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not giving up the
G3 pawn and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is King to G2
again it it's remarkable how many times
in the game King G2 is the winning move
uh and uh of course you have to uh
defend the pawn if if you capture then
first Rook captures with check and then
you capture this pawn and then black has
sufficient uh means to to draw the game
however now not so much Rook captures on
A3 was played Rook captures on e4 and
now Rook to D3 uh but now King to F2 and
this is again uh absolutely Sensational
look at this King to F2 Now Pawn to C6
ala paralyzes the game completely but
again only one winning move for Jun uh
pause the video for the second time and
win it uh once and for all
uh I'm sure you guys were now able to do
it as just you know uh uh 30 seconds ago
I mentioned it's incredible how many
times King to G2 is the winning move
here so yes King to G2 is the only
winning move here and the point is that
you put black in s Swang now any move
that black makes uh loses the game uh
the the problem is you have to keep an
eye on the G3 Pawn also so you have to
keep an eye on the third rank you cannot
allow King to F3 if King to F3 then King
F4 and then the king just comes into the
game and gobbles up all of the pawns and
if you leave the defense of the D4 Pawn
Yeah G3 Pawn not so much but if you
leave the defense of the D4 Pawn uh then
The Rook is able to roam and The Rook
will no longer have to guard the D4 Pawn
so you have to decide whether you allow
the king into the game or you allow The
Rook into the game and the king is the
most powerful piece in the end game so
of course alza decides to um uh well he
he decides uh to to let the king in the
game but uh other moves that don't
really help you like if Rook D2 check
King F3 and if you go Rook to A3 to sort
of keep the king at Bay then Rook E5 you
just go after the kingside pawns and if
Rook back to D3 going after this Pawn
Rook G5 and if captures captures uh
that's pretty much it Rook to D5 can be
played but Rook G5 I mean white can
never trade Rooks white is up black can
never trade Rooks as white is up a pawn
and once you give a check and King f
three that's pretty much all there is
King to D6 Rook captures on H5 you're up
two Pawns of of course completely
winning so Al Isa tried Rook to D1 he
has to try something you know other
moves are are just U over too quickly
King to F3 uh she gets her King finally
into the game Rook to F1 check King to
E3 uh Rook back to F7 and now she plays
Rook to F4 she did take her time
considering our moves here but the
problem for ala is that all of the moves
are winning uh Rook to F4 we have Rook
to G7 and now King to D3 uh King to E6
by Ala now comes Rook to f8 grabbing
hold of the back rank uh Rook to A7 and
now King to
E4 uh King to E4 is is a nice touch sort
of an elegant way to finish the game
because you could also sacrifice the G3
pawn and just go for The Rook D6 check
right away to pick up this pawn and then
two connected pass points of course will
be unstoppable but she plays it uh you
know to to be the absolute most precise
she plays King to E4 and now there's
nothing left for ala to do he did play
this Rook to A1 move but after Rook to
d8 he was in this position un move 64
that alira fua resigned the game and I
just realized I uh misspelled his name
so sorry about
that yeah that's what I get you know for
not copy pasting names for you know I'll
just write it myself like I can you know
write a write a name
uh yeah it was in this position that ala
fua resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so
brilliant brilliant Victory by the
Women's World Champion ju Wun uh who uh
as I've said before is having uh well a
pretty solid tournament I mean she she
Drew against Yani pishi and she defeated
ala fuja if any if anyone did that in a
tournament uh they'd be having a great
tournament it's only round five she did
lose two games but even that um game
against Anish giri in round one was uh I
mean it was incredible uh incredible
game very very difficult and uh it was
you know only due to anish's Brilliance
that he really stick to it and he really
really played brilliantly the entire
game uh that she uh finally you know
succumbed to his brilliancy but other
than that she's playing some incredible
chess here and I'm very much looking
forward to seeing uh what she does next
uh so yeah tough a tough break for alira
who was only half a point behind the
leader Anish giri and now is knocked
back a full point but what are you going
to do everyone plays uh really strong
here and you did play a world champion
uh so yeah once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Mark Henley Brennan Brian pin yunyang
Carol bot and Johan clens for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
day